[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and we got some mind-blowing
information in this chapter chapter 106
in fact vital information that many of
us have been wondering about for a long
time has been cleared up what happened
to Annie
when will Eren unlock the phantom Titan
powers
what is Zeke's plan all of these
important questions have been addressed
in Chapter 106 and I'm pretty excited to
talk about it if you like attack on
titan content on this channel give that
like button a colossal arm and smash and
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you never miss a
new vid like last time I made a post on
Instagram and Twitter at anime uproar
where I'm asking you guys to predict
what will happen in the next chapter so
chapter 107 if you're right I'll shut
you out in the next vid stay tuned to
see who correctly predicted the events
of this chapter now without further ado
let's do it
so if you remember last chapter our main
characters escaped successfully but in
the process Sasha our precious potato
girl was killed by Gabi arguably the
most hated character in the fandom by
this point this chapter starts on a
seashell and the person holding it says
if I were to tell you about something
like this think that you'd get worried
over it
we don't know who's talking who they're
talking to or why they're holding a
seashell but more on that later then we
jumped three years into the past
our s wavy Yolo on Instagram correctly
predicted that we get flashbacks of what
happened during the time skip and how
Aaron made his decision I was really
hoping for this and I'm glad we got it
we see Mr layin ship making it two
parodies and bam Aaron's attacked
tightened using his insane power comes
out of the water and picks up the giant
ship this reminds me of when the owl
Ehren Kruger and LDN restorationist who
infiltrated them are laying army
similarly lifted up a ship so many years
ago however history does not repeat
itself this time and instead of
destroying it Aaron carries over to ship
on land before throwing it down the toun
quickly
and becomes more humorous when we see
the eccentric kanji welcoming the
captured Marlon soldiers to parodies
this is a hilarious moment because
instead of treating them as enemies
hanji treats them our lands as valued
guests and even offers them tea
this is an important shift in the story
because up to this point chronologically
speaking there was little attempt made
by either side to bridge the gap and
work together the Marlon Nicolo is
resisting even while Levi is holding a
blade to his back and hundra is saying
that they'll all be such close friends
in no time back when Aaron picked up the
ship someone called him a devil and now
Niko uses the term devil again and asked
the Merlin soldier to shoot down the
devil's referring to our island dwelling
homies again you see some hardcore
racism here the Marlin in charge says
the LD UNS have filthy blood and in
response to the t offer says he wouldn't
sip on the cup of pig's piss with you
filthy lot the marlane commander is so
brainwashed that he caused the LD n
Devils one more time before he's gonna
shoot at hanji thus rather than talk he
would sooner kill and get killed
it is well-established at this point
that the Marlins have been conditioned
to view the L beings as lesser subhuman
and even anti human as Devils who simply
want to destroy life on earth this
conditioning is about to climax and the
marlane commanders shot when luckily in
the nick of time
Jelena the follower of Zeke from last
chapter shoots him through the head and
accepts Hajis invitation for tea from
this point on the Marlins on board the
ship along with the other soldiers from
other nations start to slowly challenge
their ideology which assumes that LD
ends especially Island darling LD ins
are not human and as hanji predicted
eventually some become closer and closer
with the so called Devils the fact that
this is a flashback means we get more of
Sasha but everything she does is tainted
by the knowledge that she's gonna die
which even serves to make scenes that
would have been comic relief in the past
somewhat tragic after the intense it
exchange and after Jelena shoots the
Marlin in the head
Mikasa has to wake up Sasha and remind
her not to fall asleep the fact that
Sasha is not around in the present
timeline anymore is significant
precisely because of the kind of
character she was like in this instance
she would always lighten the mood she
would make the survey Corps along with
us laugh at her antics and the terrible
events that were always taking place
would seem a little more bearable Sasha
was really a rare light in this
otherwise extremely dark world and the
fact that that lights been extinguished
has implications for the story it seems
like this world is going to get bleaker
and bleaker and in such a world there's
no room for innocent silly characters
like Sasha however even her last words
in the last chapter meet were surely an
attempt to lighten everyone's mood one
last time moving on Jelena who I gotta
say I liked as a character and not just
because my cousin's name is Jelena
shares Malayan technology with hanji and
tells kanji that Marlay has roughly 1
million soldiers which is nothing
compared to the tens of millions of wall
Titans that are supposedly in the walls
but not taking the colossal Titans into
account it's a pretty daunting number
and forced to deal with especially since
as Yana says they have air power which
scares hanji however Jelena explains
that they didn't attack yet because a
they fear the pure Titans between the
outer wall of Paradise Island and the
inner walls being unaware that the
survey corps has pretty much taken care
of the Titans between the walls and B
they are not attacking because they are
warring with several Allied nations on
the outside leaving them too preoccupied
to worry mainly about the island Jelena
says that many foreign countries that
have been devastated by Marlay are
itching to fight against them Jelena is
a member of one such nation she was
drafted as a soldier and she was
helpless to do anything besides fight
for her oppressors until she met Zeke
who showed her and the others that there
is hope despite the fact that Marley and
the world
I'm a devil Jelena claims that he's a
God so not only is she a follower of Z
she used him as a god
which is interesting to me let me know
what you guys think in the comments
about Zeke's role as a savior or even as
a God I am intrigued by the cost and
flipping the Titans are at different
times referred to as Devils and others
as gods
yamir was called the god and rod Rhys
believed that the power of the founding
titan made one into a god and the
colossal Titan was referred to the god
of destruction and even later in this
chapter when yank upon which hopefully
is how you say it says that God gave
Amir her powers whereas most Marlins
believed that Amir fretts made a deal
with the devil and that's how she got
her powers the religious overtones are
definitely interesting and I look
forward to seeing how they play out we
could definitely get Aaron taking on a
christ-like role and taking all of the
world's burdens on his shoulders and per
a loose style but I'm kind of hoping for
a more original ending let me know what
you guys think
jelena reveals that not only did she
shoot down a high-ranking officer on
Zeke Yeager's orders she reveals that
there is an anti male faction and that
their purpose is the liberation of the
LDN people this is noteworthy because
they are not LD and restorationist Zeke
is not trying to revive the great aldia
Empire rather he is simply trying to
free his people a big difference that
separates him from the political goals
of OWL and more importantly Grisha Jager
UF teacher pet are on Instagram asked an
interesting question he says something
really confuses me
if Zeke said to Aaron that their father
brainwashed them wouldn't it make more
sense for Aaron to come to the Marlin
side this is a good question since Zeke
betrayed his father after all
and clearly doesn't agree with him but
that does not mean that he agrees with
Marley either perhaps what Zeke meant is
that Grisha brainwashed Aaron with his
LD and restorationist ideas and taught
him to blindly hate his enemies Zeke
doesn't appear to want to follow his
father and the LD in restoration
ideology because that is the same as the
Malayan ideology only the oppressors and
the oppressed switch places rather what
appears to be the goal of seek secret
plan is the liberation of the LD ins and
the end of all oppressive empires so
those are my thoughts on that thanks for
the great question Pettit and if you
guys want me to answer any specific
questions leave them in the comments of
this video anyways we jump to a scene
taking place in the courtroom they are
discussing Zeke's plan and a lot of
people feel that they cannot trust the
Zeke because of what he did in the past
killing survey corps members and turning
other LD ins into mindless Titans now
yes this is messed up but his end goal
is the survival and liberation of the LD
M people and like Aaron Krueger who had
to kill and torture many LD ins as an
undercover agent as the owl
it appears that for Zeke the ends
justify the means he is willing to
sacrifice Audion lives in order to try
to ensure the safety and future of the
majority
we also learned very valuable
information in this scene namely that in
order to use the founding Titans powers
more than just royal blood is needed
historia is not enough
Aaron was able to use the coordinate
only once when he made contact with Tina
fritz
Zeke's mother who had royal blood and
was a Titan now Z confirms for us that
indeed the Royal blooded person must be
a Titan for the power to work thus I can
totally picture Eren just riding like a
boss on the Beast Titans shoulders and
using the coordinate power in the
present timeline this is finally
possible and it appears that we finally
have the key to unlocking the founding
Titans powers which means that Aaron
will be able to control the tens of
millions of colossal Titans in the walls
Aaron also gives us a name for the
ability to awaken the Titans to trample
the world earth and rumbling information
that Aaron might have got from memories
of previous founding Titan users keep in
mind guys that contact with Zeke may
also
help awaken the other founding titan
powers the ability to manipulate LDN
memories and remember with precise
detail all the experiences of previous
Valentine users all of this can actually
happen in the upcoming chapters which is
insane we are no doubt going to have
some big things happening soon however
the problem is that most officials
within the walls are just as closed off
from working with outsiders as many
outsiders are closed off to working with
the Devils on the island they even want
to hang Jelena and the others who
offered to help but hanji convinces them
not to just as with the closed-minded
marlane commander who is about to shoot
at hanji in the beginning of the chapter
the government officials within the
walls refused to consider working with
any outsiders and believe that they are
all enemies that should be killed then
we jump to Jelena tricking a ship to get
close using wireless communications and
colossal Armand appears so does Levi and
using the words of the previous Merlin's
he says welcome to the dirty island of
filthy Devils
help yourself to some pig piss which is
pretty funny
I guess that's his impersonation of
hanji speech they capture more merlin
soldiers and probably convince some to
work for them Oh an echo point reveals
plans for the island dwellers to build a
dock so they can dock their ships and
establish commerce with other nations of
the world after wondering if a dog can
be eaten Sasha
innocently asks how onion component is
black.here it seems to me that onion
component gives another clue to the
philosophy of the anti merlion faction
he answers Sasha that the one who
created us or God had this way of
thinking that it would be more
interesting to have different types of
people the people who became Titans the
subject of Amir are the same we all
exist because he desired it therefore we
have here a philosophy of the world
where everyone is desired to exist there
are no races that are
Bulls not even Marlins we jump to a
scene where Nikola is preparing seafood
something that the LD ins never had he
still seems to be a bit judgmental of LD
ins but he blushes when Sasha
compliments his cooking and calls him a
genius along with Nikola engineers from
other nations begin to work with the
survey Corps and improve their
technology Armin optimistically says
that we certainly understand each other
which shows how bridging the gap between
aliens and other nations is possible
although I will take time however as
Aaron points out they don't have time
Aaron says Zeke's life span won't be
longer than three more years and
remember this flashback started three
years in the past so they're quickly
running out of time Armin wants to wait
and build the harbor's and discuss
misunderstandings with Marlay and other
nations but Aaron thinks he's being
naive there is no misunderstanding and
the rest of the world views them as
monsters well Mekas and Armin focus on
the fact that the Marlins and others
will become their friends in time and it
reminds them that they are short on time
and they need to buy time by preventing
any interference then we jump to Sasha
being shot and Armin wondering if maybe
there was a different way that they
could have gone about the whole plan
Armin points out that there was a
funeral for eight people who died so go
stalker one five six on Instagram was
right on target there we figured out
that Armin is holding the seashell he
admits that he is struggling because
Aaron chose to ignore the court and
government officials and go alone - me -
Zeek
many people were killed as a result
civilians included and Armin admits that
they did the same thing that happened to
them on that day when Reiner bad thought
and Annie infiltrated the walls although
Armin says that Aaron's actions have cut
off the path to reconciliation he also
believes that they had no other choice
and then he says just like you guys
didn't and then we figure out that Armin
is talking to the one the only the
long-awaited Annie who is still inside
her crystal three years late
I think it's a great sign that we
finally saw her though because I hope
this means that she'll be getting out of
there soon as the war harem Titan
revealed she might be conscious at the
time and able to hear Arman's words let
me know what you guys make of the
seashell in the comment was it from a
previous chapter I don't remember I'm
not sure but I do think it's meaningful
for armed and especially because he
always as a kid wanted to go to the
ocean
that was his innocent and optimistic
dream however this scene shows how much
has changed the ocean is no longer
fantasy but just another stage for war
it reminds us of just how much Armin too
has changed since those innocent days
the chapter closes Levi's picking on
Zeke with a shot of Falcon Gabi in jail
so shout out to Kim ran and John
Baptiste for calling that finally we get
the lines that have been repeated
throughout the series because of holding
Aaron's scarf to her at the gravesite
begins saying if we don't win we die if
we win we'll survive
then we jump to Aaron finishing it off
saying if we don't fight we can't win so
fight again they only have two options
fight or die and Aaron's definitely made
his decision and wow what a chapter guys
so much important info revealed and
they're really setting the stage for
some epic moments in the upcoming
chapter I'm talking founding Titan
abilities Yeager brother teamwork and he
coming out of the crystal and we even
have the final battle to look forward to
now the Falco and Gabi have been
captured I think that Reiner may even be
tempted to come over to this side
whatever happens I think that this
chapter was one of the most informative
ones we've got to date remember to leave
your predictions of the next chapter on
the Twitter and Instagram posts darkness
5 4 2 4 AKA lightning darkness was
definitely right that the focus on this
chapter would be on Paradise Island
thank you all for sending in your
predictions and although we didn't have
any correct ones on Twitter
this time I think we all share attack on
acraman sentiment when he says rest in
peace asha may you live in the LD ins
afterlife hunting and eating potatoes
and meat indeed that's it for today's
video
wow it's late at night now that i'm
writing this and i spent way more time
on this than i expected to this will
probably be a long review but I can't
help it I get into it and I gotta share
my thoughts on these events with you
guys make sure to like if you enjoyed
the video and subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you haven't and
type in hashtag free dld ins if you
actually made it this far because that
would be pretty damn impressive and I
want to know if you did also it gives
you the opportunity to spread the love
for the LD ins anyways until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]